To the beholders that I thought mattered, I was still unbeautiful.
And my mother again would say to me, "You can't eat beauty."
"It doesn't feed you."
And these words plagued and bothered me.
I didn't really understand them until finally I realized...
...that beauty was not a thing that I could acquire or consume,...
...it was something that I just had to be.
And what my mother meant when she said, "You can't eat beauty," was that...
...you can't rely on how you look to sustain you.
What actually sustains us, what is fundamentally beautiful is compassion...
...for yourself and for those around you.
That kind of beauty inflames the heart and enchants the soul.
It is what got Patsey in so much trouble with her master...
...but it is also what has kept her story alive to this day.
We remember the beauty of her spirit...
...even after the beauty of her body has faded away.
And so I hope that my presence on your screens...
...and in magazines may lead you, young girl, on a similar journey.
That you will feel the validation of your external beauty...
...but also get to the deeper business of being beautiful inside.
That there is no shade in that beauty.
Thank you.